yes I was part of the playing game with
Mark Davis the owner of the Raiders and
it's me back in 1996 my flock of
seagulls err back on my SportsCenter
days I beat Mark Davis and then got in
as the 16 seed and over the weekend you
all voting on this had me as the UMBC
knocking off Troy Polamalu the 1 seeds
out Clay Matthews the 2 seed is still in
he's now the highest seed in this here
tournament also over this past weekend
Deion Sanders in the last 24 hours the
Jerry Cole curl version of Deion Sanders
lost to Randy Moss in his afro days
Randy Moss has now moved on he cuts down
me if you will hair nets if they just
let your soul glow region
he's the 10 seed advances and he's not
the only first ballot hall-of-famer
that's trying to cut down hair nets from
this year's Canton class next up trying
to cut down the hair nets of the region
in which I advanced the hair version of
me from 1996 taking on the bald Brian
Urlacher who upset in the 512 matchup
the 12th seeded bald
Urlacher upset the 5th seeded Urlacher
with hair in the pantene region to take
on me it's the 12 16 matchup
Urlacher ball vs. me with hair and now
here on the Rich Eisen show me bald with
the Urlacher with hair here on the
program how are you Brian that was
really confusing I'm great first ballot
Hall of Famer Brian Urlacher here on the
show and we'll get to that in a second
but the matter at hand here Brian is
yeah your Polamalu well first thing no
way that should ever happen I agree I
agree but you know what Cinderella
stories happen Cinderella stories happen
and it was me from 1996 if you recall I
really I remember that oh I do yeah
what's better than well I wouldn't say
better than now I'm just saying
different than now but at the same time
we decided in the 512 matchup which you
know is always in the n-c-double-a
tournament that's well that's what well
speed or my foot we see here is that you
were both the five seed was you and your
current bike that Lou I couldn't lose
them yeah well you and your current form
looking very dapper with your with your
Lin against the twelve seated Urlacher
back in your day it's the head shot of
you you know just staring straight into
space getting ready to dismantle
somebody from the center of the Bears
defense the bald
Urlacher beat the the B earlier with
hair what was the font the final tally
on that was a blowout the final of
people know me as bald so I think that's
the what that's the reason why I thought
that's what I'm gonna go with at least
mmm
I mean the final the final is 76 24 is
three to one beat down so are you fine
with that Brian you do with that yeah me
yeah you know I look it's not to say
that I have a good shape bald head as I
told you before so you know I wasn't mad
with the way my head looked ball I like
it better now but I was okay with it
being bald as well so now I know you're
a competitive man yeah do you want the
what do you think of the matchup of you
of your bald days taking on me and my
non bald days Brian hair days in my hair
days well I mean the people have already
spoken with my 76244 Sonny's victory
over the guy was hair already so I would
think that it's gonna be similar numbers
in my favor okay let's take it unless
people just completely hate me with hair
and that's why that's why the numbers
are simple for above me no I don't think
they hate you with hair it's just the
restore people are telling you to say
when you're out there is that the line
they give you all I now a crucial thing
here Brian there's this is what I was
thinking about breeding
in preparing consider I prepare for
interviews I don't know if you can tell
I've prepared for all morning okay so
now for your bust and Canton it's got a
ball from your playing days where your
ball right and your bust
yeah how are you gonna square that
circle of you walking around with a full
head of hair and everyone's gonna walk
in a Canton and see you ball for the
rest of everybody's days Brian you
finally think about stuff like that
honestly I'm not worried about it rich I
think I'm not worried about it but
that's the least of my worries
I know that everything's going great for
you so you have not instructed the the
gentleman who's in charge of the bust to
put the current or lacquer turtle we are
we are doing or lacquer as you was most
of his playing career okay fantastic all
right now let's get to the serious stuff
congratulation it by the way I saw you
that night obviously backstage how does
it how have you just been thinking about
walking around being reminded every now
and then first ballot first ballot Hall
of Famer
yeah right it's a lot I mean it's a much
better conversation now that's there
like hey what do you think now how you
feeling you think you're gonna be able
to get in there this year and there's
some great players in that ballot which
there were but it now it's a much much
more fun conversation you know talking
about oh yeah you're in finally we knew
you'd get in love everyone knows that
when you get in you know there's no
questions after they party you know
bojay and so it's exciting not still
good fun it's still fun to talk about
the crazy thing is it's a pain in the
butt planning for this thing it's a big
deal
I mean how oh my god won't we through it
here Brian what do you mean I mean you
got to get your whole family there you
got your friends there's a list you so
now the people that you want they're
like terrific people on the list and
they have to email it out to them they
have to respond and there's no place to
stay again um
there's rooms there's tickets for this
tickets for that travel okay just it's
crazy so it's kind of like you're
getting married Brian
it really is way worse way WAY worse I
like that everything's good she was
great it was not well how many people
are coming
how many people were at your wedding how
many people 200 and something maybe so
this is gonna be larger so so we were
smart because we did it like a
destination thing so we knew people we
divided wouldn't come knowing that they
wouldn't come because the destination we
had it was really hard to get to so we
we did the good thing so I'm kind of
same way it's not easy to get to either
I was about to say I was insulted that I
didn't get invited to your wedding but I
didn't well I don't want a token invite
I don't want token invite yeah well it'd
have been easy for you get just it was
on Palm Springs to you two got down I
[Laughter]
love it I'd rather you tell me to my
face I don't even want you there that
did give me a token I didn't want you
there I just you didn't get invited
okay now you'd like to tighten the
rotation you tighten the rotation just
like the playoffs so how did you just
how did you come about name tabbing
you're linebacker coach Bob Babbage to
be your presenter that's a hard decision
because there are so many people who
influence my pro career you know in a
good way you know coach Greg Blas was my
first defensive coordinator here the
huge impact on my career early on Coach
Smith obviously came in I was a head
coach so bob was the guy spend most of
my time with I feel like he had the
biggest impact on me throughout my
career he made me better he challenged
me every single day and not only honest
with other Phil he's a great father he's
a great man
I has a great family just a great role
model for me to kind of try and pattern
myself after not you know another
football player but as a man you know
he's a great man just always he was
always there for me whether it was good
bad indifferent I know I could call Bob
and get a straight answer from him no
matter what it was about so I
appreciated that and just a really good
friend of mine someone I look up just
over there there's a tough decision but
also an easy one heavy starter on your
speech at all I've been almost crazy I
started right after we got a call that
we were getting in and then I have
Oregon since I wrote down like eight
pages quick okay this is gonna be easy
this is nothing and then I just got
stalled
haven't really done a whole lot I think
I'm just gonna wing it though man no not
not winging it but get up there because
I know what I want to say about
everybody but so just write down their
name and just say what I want to say
about them okay that makes sense I just
you know look not winging it cuz I want
to leave anybody out I know that cuz
when you wing it then you wind up like
Favre was still talking you know what I
mean
walk well they're cutting us off this
year we have a strict amount of time so
you know when when Kurt went in he was
on at midnight Eastern I know nobody was
watching and no one was in there no one
was in the place either what do you mean
they're cutting you off Brian what do
you mean what do they tell the time of
allegedly we have a time limit this year
like what are they gonna play the music
like the Academy Awards Oscars yeah I
don't know I don't know how but you know
what's going last year I know me you my
name is Park to be you no no no no I
don't think it goes alphabetically like
that you should so after the August
whatever I'll come back on your show and
we'll talk about me going last again and
then we can replay this if you say no no
no no and then they'll be going laughs
you have been told you're going last
well I'm number 318 in our all time
member of yes that's alphabetically
that's alphabetical you get your number
alphabetically in your class sure that
is the way it goes so Kurt Warner was
last last year correct yeah he's just
you know I know it's W I think it's
called a coincidence yeah weird mine
starts with a u which is not far in
front of W if I'm not mistaken from my
grammar dates but yeah I think and then
in terms of again just I guess bringing
this full full full circle and put a
button on this hall of fame conversation
Brian you chose coach Bob Babbage and I
and and under that would be choice to
what of him either man coach blush who
was a coach for Coach Smith I spoke to
both of them about what I called it I
thought I actually would hunt with Greg
last weekend to Florida and I called
coach Smith and I asked them what they
thought and they both said pick Babich
you do the most here's with you the
longest we're just happy to be there you
know we're honored as you're going in
and you would consider us but take
damage but my sources tell me that if it
wasn't any of those it would have been
Jay Cutler is that true
Brian yeah he was on the list you know
rich you and your guys always bringing
stuff up I think your sources are you
you as in while you not the letter you
yeah but you got to thank him right you
play that the music is a music planner
tell me we're out of time I'm sorry at a
time your introduction by the way how do
you explain the hair game yes I guess
like four minutes Brian listen this
whole time were actually three solids on
me you did a good job I definitely know
what's going on I'm sure now you know
what's going on did the bald version
upset the hair version now it's the
modern berth with you yes let's see if
the bald can just keep on knocking
people off with hair man we'll see how
it goes no no tomorrow
you can vote right now at Rich Eisen
show it's posted going up right now
go ahead retweet it from that be
Urlacher 54 retweet it so you can go
ahead and stuff the ballot box go for
all my life I'm not gonna hey Brian
always love chat with your great
catching up with you we'll chat soon
okay you got it you got it
Brian Urlacher the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience